- Thanks to strong,
but not too strong data
on inflation, retail
sales, and economic growth
in recent months, the US
has been enjoying what
I like to call "Soft Landing Summer."
But some analysts are saying
that the recession that most
of Wall Street predicted
would hit this year
hasn't been avoided.
It's just been delayed.
And there are three big reasons why,
first, some major
and unexpected government
stimulus programs
that have held up the
economy are going away.
Second, those big piles
of pandemic savings have
been largely exhausted
for lower income households.
And third, the data we've
been seeing this summer
could mean the Fed has more work to do.
Let's get into it.
Coming into 2023, it looked like there
wouldn't be any new stimulus
coming out of Washington
because Republicans and Democrats
had split control of Congress.
That usually means nothing gets done
but because inflation was so high,
government programs automatically made
so-called cost of living
adjustments, which meant
that a lot more money was
going out to Americans
receiving government transfers.
The record setting 8.7% increase
in social security benefits
made headlines, but
that wasn't the only program
to get a major increase
in funds.
SNAP benefits for food
programs, retirement payments
from federal and state
programs, and the pay
for government contractors
also went up substantially
because these automatic increases.
That has meant a lot more money flowing
through the economy in 2023.
And because inflation has
slowed down so much this year,
those cost increases
won't be repeated in 2024.
Ed Clissold, the Chief US strategist
at Ned Davis Research also points out
that the effects of the CHIPS Act
and infrastructure bills that
pumped hundreds of billions
of dollars into the
economy are now being felt.
2024 is an election year
and with inflation still
a major talking point,
Ed doesn't expect to see a repeat
of those programs next year either.
Many of the lower income
people who rely on
government programs
have also exhausted much
or all of the pandemic
savings they built up
over the past few years,
the amount of savings folks
had put away
from government stimulus
checks, enhanced unemployment
and just not being able to go
out and spend is much lower.
Brian Rose, senior US Economist
at UBS Global Wealth Management
says the US personal savings
rate is unsustainably low.
The saving rate has dropped not just
below the record levels
we saw during the pandemic
but even below its average
over the past 10 years.
Moody's Chief Economist,
Mark Zandi tells me
that new data show
Americans at lower income tiers
are having more trouble paying
for household expenses than
at the beginning of the year.
And more Americans across
the board are having to find
irregular income sources to
meet their spending needs.
The US economy is built
on consumers buying
and that's likely to
slow down if Americans
have spent down their savings.
We're also seeing big increases
in American's credit card balances
and in credit card delinquencies.
Those two things happening
together is not great.
Last but not least, there's
the Fed, chair Jerome Powell
and the Federal Reserve have already
raised US interest rates to the highest
in more than 20 years.
But with the Fed determined
to get inflation back down
to its 2% target
and recent US GDP numbers
showing unexpected growth,
the Fed may have to keep
raising interest rates,
that would put even more pressure
on US companies,
especially small businesses
which are the economy's driving force.
Small business optimism has been below
its nearly 50-year average
for 19 straight months
making things even tougher
for small companies,
the Fed's latest survey
shows banks have tightened
their standards for making loans
to levels that have consistently
signaled a recession
for the past 50 years.
So here's the big picture,
in 2023, inflation has slowed
down and the US economy
has held strong.
But both of those things
could be unraveling,
if inflation holds at its current levels
and consumer and business
spending keep falling,
that recession everyone predicted
in 2023 could just materialize in 2024.
(soft music)